thank you everybody and thank you for
the folks that organized this conference
a big undertaking and I try to be here
really early I left two hours ago and
just got here about a minute and a half
ago but I'm here so actually let's just
dive in and get started so the
presentation is start small and scale
and when I started small this afternoon
this morning in my garage there was no
traffic when I turned out onto the road
and Chino scale happened and this is why
we love Southern California right so so
I'm Carol I'm actually a member of
project Jupiter steering council a core
developer I'm also a core developer and
steering council member for Python the
software language and do a lot of work
with interact and have the pleasure of
every few weeks co-hosting the podcast
webcast open source directions which
actually profiles the different projects
in open source that are often used by
data scientists so really well my love
is creating tools that educate and
empower people the last five six six
years working on Jupiter has been
incredibly rewarding and it's amazing to
see the different folks that are using
it in so many different ways and we'll
talk a little bit more about interact
and how that fits into scale a little
bit later but first what's data science
there's a lot of different definitions
so I'm going to give you my definition
so that it frames the context of this
talk I view data science as using data
responsibly to solve real world issues
and improve human lives now that's my
definition it has nothing to do with
technology software tools but really
focuses in on responsibility
the world and and all of us humans so I
want to tell you a real quick real-world
tale about making predictions at scale
I live in lovely southern San Diego and
when I look at the weather outside other
than yesterday and the day before it's
typically high 60s sunny no clouds it's
pretty easy to predict the weather in
San Diego well earlier this year about a
month and a half ago I was in Europe at
the European medium range weather
forecasting group which is a big
research institution that collects tons
of data about weather across the world
and they are the ones that actually do
the weather forecasting for the next 12
to 14 days for the world as of December
2018 they have 255 petabytes of
operational and research data and
they're adding 250 terabytes a day and
overall they have more than 400 billion
fields stored in their Mars
database so that's a little bit of a
scale right so earlier this year I spent
some time in Tokyo visiting my daughter
she's a Japanese translator the weather
was gorgeous and on October 12th was
when I landed in Heathrow to go visit
the weather agency and earlier that week
the Sunday before I landed there was a
big typhoon heading towards Japan and
this is actually a picture of the
weather forecast that this institution
had made and Japan I don't know if you
can really see it but it's directly
under the green and red so looks like a
direct hit in terms of probability a
week before
if we go to the leave its the Tuesday
before I landed in Heathrow this is what
the hurricane the typhoon looked like
out over the ocean you can see the eye
it's pretty massive and in terms of
context the Wednesday before I landed
that was typhoon haggis and if you look
at it it's probably as big a cross as
the entire country of Japan and at that
point it was classified as a super
typhoon and the actual eye which you can
maybe see a little bit on the bottom is
60 kilometers in diameter so a little
tiny storm so I get off the plane in
Heathrow and all of a sudden my phone
starts pinging ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding nickname I have a ton of
messages from my daughter and usually
she's she's my independent one and
nothing really fazes her and she's like
mom in case you haven't seen there's a
super typhoon headed straight towards
Tokyo I've been translating emergency
messages for the entire day but I
thought you want to know and so in
response what do I say I can't do
anything I'm like be safe and to that
response she sent me this picture and
this is the eye getting close to where
she is in Tokyo and the sky actually
changes a different color because of the
I guess the pressurization and the way
light goes through it so fast forward a
little bit further the eye of the storm
kept going and the storm kept going
across Tokyo during the day my
daughter's like yeah I'm on the 4th
floor of my apartment
hopefully the windows won't explode in
but I guess I could probably run the ten
minutes over to the government office if
need be and she's like or I could just
like huddle in the bathroom and lie on
the bottom of the thing and I'm thinking
okay this is the the irony of going and
speaking at a weather Research Institute
and having this happen in the background
was sort of surreal and and she's like
oh there was a fire ooh
there was just this you know oh and we
have a little bit of a volcanic eruption
and there's a tornado that's coming
through and from that news what I
learned was some towns like Hakone near
Mount Fuji I had a metre of rain in less
than a day some areas got 40% of their
annual rainfall in that one day they had
urged 7 million people to evacuate their
homes and go to evacuation centers which
was part of what my daughter was
communicating out to folks and they had
over 27,000 troops and rescue crews
deployed to help so to quote my daughter
wind water earth and Fire all that's
left is for Godzilla to crawl out of the
bay and vaporize Chiba and at that
moment it sounded kind of plausible and
I was like that's pretty cool I'm gonna
leave it in my keynote and you know on a
more serious note that day the next day
it showed that the storm was passing
through the death toll was about 84
people at that time 33,000 plus homes
got flooded and the Tama River which is
a big river that goes through Tokyo had
just crested to the banks where she was
and that was one of the things they were
really worried that it was going to
overflow because you know
everything's flat sort of like it is in
San Diego like when we get rain we flood
and so why does this have anything to do
with data science other than we use data
to forecast the weather
well data science really mattered in
this context because it helped us
predict what was going to happen so they
had at least a week's warning to start
mobilizing forces on the ground within
the government to start evacuating
people and have they not done that the
death toll would have been far higher
than what it ultimately was overall
there was over nine billion dollars of
damage done by this one tight super
typhoon and it's sort of astounding that
income in contrast it was things that
got lost as opposed to many people and
that is one reason that data science
really matters I'm gonna give you
another quick example of why I think
data science matters and with great
scale of data comes great responsibility
and that responsibility starts with
every single person in this room the
healthcare industry there's a company
down in San Diego it makes little
monitors that read glucose levels and
they have this whole integrated system
around it so the CEO had said in early
November
this whole integration of healthcare
data is really going to be the next
frontier so think about it for a moment
you're making a service and product
that's measuring people's glucose level
and that is also alerting them
and people who are subscribed to their
stream that the glucose level is
dropping or you know just have time to
take some intervention now if you are
doing that service as your own product
what would be some of the things that
you would perhaps plan for well one
would be an outage and stuff happens
those of you that work in the
infrastructure side of things you know
things break and on the Friday night
right after Thanksgiving
they had a mysterious outage they didn't
announce the outage to their customers
until the morning Saturday morning about
eight hours later where they posted a
brief notice on Facebook okay but not
all their customers are on Facebook and
I won't go into the story because you
know there definitely had impact on
people but it took to the following it
took till Monday to get the service
partly restored so if you were a
customer using this and I'm not really
picking on them because it could happen
in many different services that we offer
but this is an example of you are
stewards of data you are stewards of how
the data is used and at the end of the
road people's lives may depend on your
data such as with the weather Southern
California Santa Ana winds fire really
important those weather predictions help
us avoid the destruction of fire here in
Southern California even if you're in a
business like Ticketmaster or Netflix
you probably see different traffic
patterns if it's raining in Southern
California for a week and people aren't
going out so there
to watch things inside or go out to a
show
so whether touches us in many different
ways so here's our challenge how do we
get from starting a service or starting
with an idea and scaling it and what I
want to share are some practical
examples of what I learned both at
Jupiter and before in building up
systems and services from the ground up
and it wasn't too long ago 2014 that the
ipython notebook changed its name to
Jupiter notebook this is a picture of
the classic notebook one-one linear
execution page that lets you combine
prose and text and graphs in 2014 in San
Diego Audrey Roy a Danny Greenfield and
I taught one of the first workshops in
using the notebooks we took Jax Jessica
McCullers ipython beginners tutorial and
we transferred it to notebooks and we
actually didn't teach from the notebooks
we taught from the command line but all
the notebooks were there on a separate
screen and they knew they were going
home with those notebooks so it really
reduced the stress of learning and it
really helped people focus on the
material because they knew they had it
when they were leaving and they could
use it after they had gone so fast
forward to today there's over 5 million
notebooks on github if you had asked me
in 2013 2014 would I anticipate that I
probably would have said no and I'm very
glad that I was wrong
in the interim Jupiter has sort of
become the de-facto state
for creating computational narratives
and doing research with data and I share
this because oftentimes people think
there's like a huge army of people that
have made these many many tools like
there's many projects under the Jupiter
umbrella and actually this is more or
less the core team that's made the
notebooks binder Jupiter hub if you ever
see them at a conference please say
thank you to them because pretty much
all of them are underpaid and overworked
and but we take great pride in what
we've done and we're human so we started
small we kept iterating we grew so the
roadmap for the rest of this
presentation is some practical advice on
how to start small how to explore the
paths to getting to scale because that
can be a really tricky like which thing
do I use you know is this gonna work is
it gonna hold up under load and we'll
talk a little bit about that and then
like the glucose monitoring company in
San Diego you're not job is not done
when you deploy it there also has to be
a way to sustain it and for those of you
that are using creating algorithms for
machine learning as it sits out there
and is used the models need to be
updated over time because you're
learning from them biases being
introduced and the models never as good
as the day you actually deploy it so
let's talk about starting small when
you're starting a new project often the
feelings are very similar to this what
do I use where do I start
is it this somebody told me are that
Julia
maybe Python but Python slow and there's
a lot of decisions to be made and so you
often wind up starting and looking at a
notebook like this it stays blank for a
while maybe you type in a few lines of
code execute them which is cool but
oftentimes if I'm trained not as a
software developer but maybe as a social
scientist I may not be able to install
things right off the bat but I want to
use them and explore them so look for
the tools in our industry where you can
try things without installing anything
binder was something that came out of
the desire to share research and
research papers unexpectedly it has
become very popular for sharing
demonstrations for running workshops and
it also far surpassed what we had
expected and as of last year there were
over two million binders launched on
that service and it's a free service
it's run by four people and the
community and those four people aren't
dedicated towards it it's a small
percentage of their job and you know
there's also collab and other things
which have a lot bigger infrastructure
behind it but binder has sort of become
the de facto standard for running
tutorials at conferences doing workshops
and scale we didn't really plan on it
initially so as you're looking at what
you're building what you choose for your
tools will matter at least initially
many of you might choose Jupiter lab
because it allows you to have multiple
windows
and pull out graphs things like that I'm
not going to go too far into Jupiter lab
because I think there's other talks
about it here but I'm happy to talk
about it later we'll just do a quick
maybe it's not quite
there's also interact is an alternative
tool which uses some of the Jupiter
folks including myself have helped build
a react based front-end for the notebook
and also components that can be reused
vs code we heard a little bit from the
folks that are here from Microsoft
yesterday and their work with
integrating notebooks into their editor
high charm has done the same so the
tools are important because if you have
a de facto standard like Jupiter I want
to share my notebook with a colleague in
Singapore now if they're using something
that's kind of like a notebook but not
adhering to the Jupiter standard I won't
be able to open it I won't be able to
execute it which becomes problematic if
you're doing anything with reproducible
research or anything that requires like
an accountability trail healthcare
government work often does so choose
your tools choose open source standards
because it's transparent you know what
goes into the actual product and
projects and there's also a lot of great
stuff out there and one of the things
you don't want to do in this exploration
phase is reinvent the wheel there are
tons of projects in the Python and are
and Julia sphere that have great
documentation that have a lot of
executable examples
look there first when you're trying to
decide what to pick because you will
have people that have gone before you
and gone through the pain of being the
first initial users and probably
improved it a lot by the time you get to
it after you've come up with some
promising libraries you know obviously
install them looking on Conda Forge for
community libraries that are up-to-date
that are easy to install with Conda
particularly libraries that have C
components in addition to Python Honda
is definitely a preferred choice there
so we're starting you guys have probably
at this point built some notebooks have
a prototype you know have used your
tools enough and now somebody comes to
you and says okay this looks pretty good
so let's try and put this in production
so where do you start maybe you have
folks in your company that can do it for
you which is ideal but not always the
case where they might say oh try it on a
smaller scale and then we'll go so how
do you turn the feeling of there's no
way I can do this into it's possible now
remember when we started building
Jupiter hub which serves notebooks to
groups of people and it it is what
binder is built on top of we thought oh
maybe 30 40 people will use it
simultaneously and we were wrong it then
went on to you know serve tens of
thousands of users simultaneously it's
used at CERN for some of their research
stuff and there's no way to know in the
moment where things are really going
go you're taking leaps of faith as you
do that and it's nice when you can have
some company in that leap of faith
so conferences like PI data la meetups
pilotes
the carpentry x' workshops if you
haven't been exposed to the carpentry
workshops they are open source
curriculum on data science and in
libraries science and as well and it's
really good content so I would really
encourage that but what you will learn
from your peers will get you to scale
faster than going it alone also look at
what academia is doing there is a lot of
work that is getting funded that
actually is the cutting edge of data
science right now and how to use data
science well within projects and this is
a the ten simple rules for reproducible
research and Jupiter notebooks is one of
them and it it goes through okay how do
you organize your notebooks so that you
can have it documented so that you can
version it properly so that you know
what you've done six months later when
your age itself like myself can't
remember what they did three days ago
and also it has really great tips on how
to share those notebooks and I have seen
predominantly in Asia but in other
places as well
notebooks being used for cross-training
corporate teams so customer service
engineering marketing they're all
collaborating over a notebook I've seen
it used in public health settings and
yeah
so we're gonna zoom through the rest of
this because I was late unless we can
have some time for the break yeah okay
good so as you're building stuff build
try change repeat iterate iterating is
how you get to scale there are some
great tools out there that I saw start
in their infancy one is a project called
IP volume that lets you do 3d
visualizations it's really slick it lets
you do things like manipulating like the
inside of somebody's body or a skull but
you could also translate that same
concept to parts if you're a
manufacturer and it will scale to large
data sets there's another very new
project out there for those of you that
are in the Biosciences called an apart
at lets you take huge data sets and
really zoom in with very little latency
to get really small areas and something
definitely worth checking out another
way to scale say you want Jupiter hub or
you want binder hub but you're figuring
it's gonna take a while to install it we
actually have some friends at the turing
institute that have made one button
deploy to Azure deploy to Google so that
you can at least get up and running so
that you can try it with a reasonable
sized group of people perhaps not
production quality but it's going to be
solid like you could do internal
workshops things like that which is
really nice because other people have
done the work of pulling these vast
different technologies together and then
it's also important while you're scaling
to remember that things keep changing
and to kiss stay up to
with what's new there's podcasts like
open source directions talk Python to me
for those of you that are using Jupiter
notebooks or data science in general
there is a phenomenal newsletter that
Tony Hearst puts together called
tracking Jupiter and it is worth
subscribing to because it has some of
the most up-to-date information about
new things that are coming out so we're
exploring we're we're we're building
we're applying best practices we feel
pretty good okay we've got something
that kind of hangs together at this
point now we want to deploy it and
sustain it and there's a lot more nuts
and bolts in that I'm not gonna lie
there is a project called voila that
will let you directly serve your
notebook to the web they the advantage
of that is in one command voila
something it will actually deploy it and
that is actually under the Jupiter
organization right well right now
production data at scale Matthew seal
who's out in the audience who I've
worked a lot with how to talk yesterday
about papermill Netflix uses a whole
bunch of data and at scale and have open
sourced a lot of really good work and I
would definitely recommend checking it
out paper mill itself will parameterize
and run notebooks for you scrapbook
which Matthew did a lightning talk about
and I wanted to do a gif of it but you
know but it lets you record and read
samples and store it out to s3 or other
places book store our stores notebooks
and computer helps you share notebooks
and these enterprise data workflows
Netflix isn't the only one so you know
look around see what other folks are
doing
because you can save yourself a lot of
time
Jupiter hub scales you can use it on
kubernetes you can use it on bare metal
it's a you know supported MOOCs of ten
thousand or a hundred thousand folks it
supports all of Berkeley's intro classes
and more again you can deploy your own
binder hub easy way to share notebooks
we've actually made it so now that we
have federated it so that we're not the
only ones bearing the cost of the my
binder service and other research
institutions are actually helping with
that and I mentioned this because all of
this code is free and open source even
the deployment information other than
security keys and things like that is
open source the turing institute put
together some good work about how to
make a binder how'd it go from notebooks
to something that shareable one of the
folks from the turing basically she did
a notebook while walking her dog in the
park and deployed it all from her cell
phone and this is pretty cool actually
then there's other projects like pan geo
which combines one of my favorite
projects tasks and as well as x-ray and
iris to provide a platform for open
Geoscience research and it is also open
source and it's actually the first time
that jupiter has gotten an NSF grant
because the NSF views it as a way to
offer at scale these services and the
suite of research tools in not just
Geoscience but they view it as a model
that then can be used in bioscience
and pick your favorite science or social
science from there so deploying
sustaining it it's possible so what are
your keys for success first and foremost
you have to choose to start if you don't
start you will get nowhere
one thing that those of you that know me
well know how annoying I can be because
I will often ask why why do we need to
add this why why this is a good idea and
in many many times why is a much more
important question than how and I think
our friends at the glucose monitoring
company had they asked why would it be
important to have a way to notify and
send a message to all of our customers
if our service is down might have been a
good thing to think about
absolutely automate the boring stuff
from start to finish if you can automate
something automate something it will
save you time it will improve your
accuracy and it also makes it much
easier to hand off to other people
you're going to iterate plan execute the
plan change the plan as needed and then
repeat keep doing that and as you're
building things out consider the
complexity of what you're building if
you can't understand it the likelihood
of somebody else understanding it is
pretty rare which is not to say you need
to understand every little bit and peace
but you need to understand why you're
doing something and how the big blocks
together and you need to have a way to
observe what's going on once you deploy
stuff at scale and perhaps the most
important thing is people in every step
of the project people are the most
valuable asset in
a data science pipeline data science
projects products and with that great
power comes great responsibility so my
call to action for you is get started
use some of the wonderful things that
are in our ecosystem today so that you
can use data responsibly solve
real-world issues and improve human
lives and should you think something's
impossible
remember it's possible and for our
Southern California lovers who like
surfing this is a big wave from a couple
months ago and this woman is surfing and
she's like in the corner but the waves
are just probably 10 12 times the size
of her so you can start small you can
scale and I leave you with that and I am
here all day happy to take questions and
want to thank you for listening and for
being here and to the organizers for
doing their thing Thanks
[Applause]